oh thank an exclusive yo what's up y'all
this is DJ premier I'm checking out my
man bootleg cab you know if it's a
bootleg that means it's got some extra
[__] that other people ain't got you
know saying but as real bootlegs and
that's fake ones he's the real when
bootleg cab big up all the time side I
75 man bootleg keV Ready Set Radio right
now I'm in the presence of a legend we
got DJ Premier what's going on brother
how are you primo man I'm good it's an
honor to interview you my favorite
producer of all time you should
appreciate it I feel like like this is
like a boyhood dream of mine like Paul's
you know but even house and DJ Premier I
could die now there it is how y'all with
the shank insulting oz I gotta just make
that album everyone it's been rumored
about the last eventually eventually we
should we spoke about it done to rock
the bells to it but he has some other
albums to release prior to that that he
said got to come first so it really is
call you know if it was me I would have
already done it but I mean it's
definitely is calling balls in his court
absolutely most definitely now on you
have had the most I think I mean you and
Dre of course everyone as far as hip-hop
heads always go back and forth whose
head you know who's the best producer of
all time right um i guess it's just
matter of taste but it's been you know a
prolific run that you're still on when
it comes to this music thing man i am
when you look back is there like any any
era in your career that that you look
back on and you enjoyed the most oh my i
enjoyed every every step of my journey
man you know saying like from the day
that i met guru and and uh you know
Craig G was the first rapper I ever met
you know saying on the phone I was like
yo Craig G's at my apartment I mean us
with me and guru got cool yeah and I'm
like were like can I say hi to him you
know think about back in Texas going to
school yeah and you know a Jewish crew
was already legendary when Marlon walls
my idol that I really pattern even my
production style after and scratching
style after was it was Molly and Molly
knows this very well you know so because
of that you know just any juice cube
crew member nax excelling with guru and
guru still an unknown to the New York
right so
so you know he's born on in Boston at
the time so that was just like a big
deal to me and and then uh you know from
there just elevated into all the stages
that you know my mission was to it and
still is to make a name for myself like
my father always instilled in me was you
know make sure you make a name for
yourself and and I'm only boy in my
family of all sisters and so you know
they're older than me and you know it's
just I'm the last one that out of my
family to just become a father six
months ago so I got a shot at my son
jaelen you know I'm saying so it did
just even with all of that every goal
was met I mean I'd be you know to become
an icon and hip-hop which I was like I
said I set out to do but to actually be
living it right it still blows me away
yeah like I mean with most musical
genres i say like a lot of times people
aren't fully appreciated till after you
pass their or after their kind of like
your relevant you don't mean in your
you're still the man man he's walking
away on 25 years old and kicking man you
know i mean but again that's for me
studying the artists that I appreciate
on all levels you know from rocks a new
way to jazz to country blues gospel I'm
into all of that so you know so when you
see the Rolling Stones still on tour I
just went to Tina Turner's concert I
just went to devo two weeks ago I saw
you tweet about that yeah incredible
that's crazy I saw them back when I was
in college but to see them now and you
know the lead singer is 61 years old and
jet you know Mark Mothersbaugh and then
Jerry jerrika salads is 68-63 right and
they were on stage ripping it down still
wearing all the different outfits here
and they were giving it off and then
they switch to the energy domes and put
on the you know that then they ripped
that off and put on the little mini
shorts with the with the the the the the
knee pads yeah they did all of that and
they all get now they all got an age be
all skinny now they all had bellies and
stuff I still tearing it up and the
crowd was just so into it was diehard
Evil fans like everybody had the energy
domes and not only that even their merch
like they had
rumors yeah I bought shirts they went on
with 3x he knows an hour 3 x's they had
their trip hop people get the
traditional shirts they had the energy
don't add all kinds of things to buy and
it was a good selection you know saying
so think that is an underrated thing it
when I go to a hip-hop concert and
there's dope Mertz yeah as long as it's
rightly price because i want you know i
went to the watch a throne tour concert
i was disappointed in their merch their
much was it wasn't that good and it was
like 40 bucks a shirt and I went and I
would've bought bought something cuz I
like we're in church I like support but
there was nothing for me to choose from
you know so and that's not a disrespect
Lu tales ahead that's not respect to
Jane and Kanye go those are my peoples
but uh you know uh you know I i I'm a
consumer and again they I mean don't get
me wrong there's different variations of
the stages that were all that now and
their audiences you know stadium ready
now so you know I'm not the only time
I've ever played arenas was opening up
for for rage against the machine on our
full clip tool you know which you know
was a good experience cuz it actually
elevated me to my performance level that
I'm at now when I DJ definitely and also
shout to the whole rage against the
machine we even asked us to open up for
them on that tour it was us and had to
drive in and you know dr. Zach near the
road trash out it's up to zachs out to
Timmy shot the time shot the south to
Brad you know that one hell of a tour
you know now I know you have over your
career you've had you know you've had
working relationships with like you know
a nice history of dope music with like
jay-z voice 259 my eyes is there anybody
on 27th Freddie Fox indeed a world bumpy
knuckles and DJ premier the collection
in stores okay CD vinyl and digital
alright um double vinyl there's a like
there's a big resurgence of I wouldn't
say resurgent but there's a big you know
wave of these new cats coming out that
are blowing up to the internet blown up
through the blogs um some of them are
dope some of them are not so dope I mean
is there anybody who you you know that
that's kind of you know got a buzz going
her or is on the way update that you're
you're you're checking for that you
would work with just whoever not off
head you know just I stand ask you work
with back mill
and that song was ill yeah well shop the
mac miller book that that was to uh I
know our agent max Hardy knew he had a
buzz going right um jazzy jeff reached
out to me and was like yo I'm doing this
mixtape work Mac Miller he really wants
to meet you and you know he really knows
his hip hop and I was like this stuff is
ok because you know it's more to hit the
audience that he has and I was like I'll
check it out and so we got on the phone
and he's like I'm in New York tomorrow
can I come by and just hang came by we
drank smoked and just chilled and before
you knew it was like six in the morning
I'm like damn at six in the morning as I
let me just make a beat and i just made
a beat and a great i'm just don't mix
tape yeah he's when the booth and we
just laid it and he's a big huge big
elephants yeah big time yes so I
appreciated that he was asking all these
big else story and I was telling all
these crazy stories funny stories about
Big L so he would just sit and he SAT
there really attended like wow which I
would have been that day when and all he
did different funny situations with Big
L so I appreciated that and then on top
of that I see a lot of his fans I saw a
fan of his tweet yo thanks to Mac Miller
I've never heard of a tribe called quest
and that's something I bought and I'm by
buying all their albums this is amazing
hip-hop you know so he pays homage in
here he's genuine and he tells he is a
january generally is genuine man i told
him the data here went gold and the day
that I became honest a yo-yo yeah I said
congratulations he said man I'm not even
going i'm standing in my mom i'm
standing in the house i'm not even going
out I say yo just don't let it get to
you this is the stage where you're being
tested on getting the ego or staying
chill I said so I said trust me we've
all been there and he's like I and he
said man I appreciate the advice I like
Mac bellies a good good dude I'd like
him even if he wasn't rapping he's a
cool genuine kid most definitely I'm
speaking of big al he's one of my
favorite rappers no diggity Mon to ya
straight up no finesse you you had a
really close relationship with Big O in
today's hiphop landscape um I mean I
always big I was you know he had his
flamboyant everything it was rumors he's
gonna be signing with Jay right um if
you were to speculate like I mean I mean
he was such a talented MC
in 2012 I mean what are some things you
like like do you think would be
different if bigger was still alive cuz
I really thought he was like man he was
on his way to being like like you know
Jay Z Kai you know Kanye nas type status
veil was alive now it would really be
hard for a lot of artists to even get in
the game on the level that they're at
now that goes a big Park you know pawn
everybody they were still living now it
would be so book of the lyrical the
lyrical story would have been way higher
to reach like when I got into hip-hop
the the the bar was so high you couldn't
even see it you had to climb that high
up in the sky did even if you say I
think I see the ball as people who who
can spit that work now that were like
successful yes you to respect for
spitters you now your eyes can be just
the worst ever even just the the party
fun rappers had rhymes exactly man like
you look at someone like like I little
Wayne's got dope music but the Carter
for sold like a million records right in
my opinion it was it was terrible three
was a great album 3 was delves great and
it was though and I'm proud of waiting
for stepping up his rom game from his
childhood too though I definitely where
he's made progression but I'm just
saying like I think you know maybe 10
years ago before the internet you know
came over came around music was so
accessible I just don't I just don't see
that like a an album like that in that
much love like it's just crazy like the
best songs of the album where the
interludes with nas and you know Bun B
and Boston everybody three stacks and
all that um you and I have a mutual
appreciation for pornography mess I'm a
porn head for real i mean 'animal i did
cuz uh cuz you know the the conventions
canadians is coming again yes yes I've
gone I'm in eight years solid now my
favorite porn stars abella anderson
everybody's on a bell and Santa oh right
actually have it right here in my phone
chapter julesjordan product to my studio
a couple weeks ago in my hips here very
Downers you know she represents Miami
and yeah you know she's good people
shopped abella anderson uh yeah he's our
hot thing right now you're acting right
definitely got some rotation so [__] all
the waste I feel about I slip on oh very
very very much love that ice yes have
you ever heard of skin
I'm and skin diamond um okay yo that's
the new one you guys go check that out
today she's up and coming now while wank
tube yeah yeah yeah yeah yo hit the red
tube xvideos whatever you know way to go
to wait too yea i meant to check that
out I went to a choir that was my
district was cool but what go gotta wait
to wank to and pull abella anderson she
they got rows and rows of us stuff who
are yourself some of your favorite porn
stars like if you had like top five well
I definitely will see I'm more it's just
like with hip-hop I'm into the older
yeah Donna is like she she took a
baseball bat there yeah buddy buddy
buddy I mean if you want it but you want
to talk about even getting gruesome with
it you could talk about julie knight who
allowed me hanging up on julie night i
heard the name but I because I looks
weren't all that but she's done the mat
most massive stuff the unpretentious way
when you deal with somebody like Joe
Silveira who goes way back the crazy
crazy ownership yeah what was the crazy
section you talking about porn a lot of
things a lot of the Sasha grades and all
of them came through Joey first and he
so yeah well you know when you're
talking about let you know from bri and
all the girls they were these are early
stages you look up julie night and look
how extreme yoga belladonna like I'm not
in the white girls at all right well I'm
esta bella donna just based on the [__]
that she doesn't videos yeah listen i
saw i saw julie night she came she came
up as a mormon tunis yeah i saw
interview about her whole career when
she started i saw julie night at that
the convention and no one was at her
booth and we walked over to her name a
boy he will pick up to him and we were
like yo the what you did in the room
with something you know I stopped you
and she was like yo y'all have made my
day because we were it like coming out
of like she's Michael Jackson you know
saying like yo when you did this one you
did this you did this
did this check on to that like five to
eight heroes in like she was you just
see how happy she was that we knew that
much you know about him kind no one was
sure we'll even stop by my ass she's a
chick stand there we were like yo there
goes julie night and again she you know
III mean you take it back to vanessa del
rio I mean she won the first extreme
people I actually wrote a a thing in her
she put out a book and they asked me
back then wasn't you in the porn would
you write a little thing what you think
of vanessa del rio i wrote a two page
little short little little statement she
reached out to me and I never met her
and she was like yell what you wrote
about me because I told her that she's
the one that to making things more
extreme to gonzo stuff and all that
before they even was gonzo she took it
to the level where she created the the
belladonna's what vanessa del rio has
has birth and she was like yell what you
wrote about me with one of the illest
parts of my book she's I'm gonna
actually move it to the front of my book
and I haven't made me I really feel good
that you know I actually want to be like
hey you wanna [__] now but uh shout
shout to Vanessa's if I had any kind of
fame in this world i would i would do
all I could he's like a young nice like
iono angel back in the day okay yeah you
know she wasn't in for a long time but
it's far as nice black women with just
super bird dog you know I on Angel she
did a lot of um you know the major stuff
you know I know Steve home just always
railing evilangel stuff you know they
got all this [__] everybody loves loves
pinky you know think you get pinky pinky
is like hit or miss man you love her or
hate her cuz she's like kind of she's
like kind of like a major but she's not
yeah you small as hell she but she's
banging